the funeral of Queen Elizabeth II will
be held at Westminster Abbey the resting
place of monarchs and the traditional
site of State funerals for centuries
ahead of the service the funeral
procession will escort the Queen's
coffin to The Abbey from the houses of
Parliament where it's been lying in
state
the coffin draped with the Royal
Standard will be born on the state gun
Carriage of the royal Navy
the Royal Marines will lead the
procession around Parliament Square
behind senior members of the royal
family including her children and the
King will be accompanied on the journey
to the Abbey by the sound of Mast pipes
and muffled drums
the procession will enter the Great West
door of Westminster Abbey at exactly 11
o'clock marking the start of the funeral
service
the queen will be carried past the grave
of the unknown Warrior and down the Nave
of the Abbey
following as they pass under the ornate
gilded entrance to the choir will be the
Archbishop of Canterbury and other
senior clergy
and then the coffin followed by the king
and senior members of the royal family
will be taken to the very heart of the
Abbey the Lantern and placed in front of
the high altar
members of the royal family will be
seated alongside
behind them in the South transcept heads
of state leaders and royalty from around
the world
sitting opposite holders of the Victoria
and George cross the counterparts from
the Commonwealth and members of the
nation's highest order of chivalry
while the Prime Minister former Prime
Ministers and the leaders of Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland will sit in
the Abbey's choir stalls
the dean of Westminster will lead the
service lessons will be read by the
Prime Minister and the Secretary General
of the Commonwealth the sermon will be
given by the Archbishop of Canterbury
at the end of the service the last post
will be sounded from the gothic Splendor
of the lady Chapel resting place of
kings and queens including Elizabeth the
first going back 700 years
a two-minute silence will be observed
throughout the United Kingdom before the
revelry is Sound by trumpeters of the
household Cavalry and in the Abbey the
national anthem is sung
the Final Act in the service will be a
procession of the Queen's coffin back
through the choir and along the Nave out
of the Abbey and back onto the state gun
Carriage before it's taken to Windsor
and her final resting place